>> Bret: TONIGHT, WE CONTINUE
OUR SERIES ON KIDS AND CULTURE.
HOW MUCH IS TOO MUCH HIGH-TECH?
AND HOW IT CAN BE A VERY BAD
THING FOR YOUR CHILDREN.
THEY EVEN HAVE A FANCY NAME FOR
IT NOW.
CORRESPONDENT ALLISON BARBER
TELLS US WHAT THIS IS, WHAT IT
MEANS AND WHAT CAN BE DONE.
>> ALL PARENTS WANT WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR KIDS.
THEY WANT THEM TO BE HEALTHY,
HAPPY.
BUT WHAT A SMALL THING.
>> FOOTBALL AND MINECRAFT.
>> THREATEN THAT.
>> IT'S VERY WORRISOME BECAUSE
IT'S SO PART OF OUR LIVES.
>> DANA IS A MOM OF THREE.
>> A 14-YEAR-OLD, 11-YEAR-OLD
AND 8-YEAR-OLD.
>> AND THEY, LIKE SO MANY OF US,
ENJOY TECHNOLOGY.
ESPECIALLY HER YOUNGEST.
>> SOMEBODY TOOK IT AWAY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GAME, WOULD YOU BE
A LITTLE BIT MAD?
OR NOT REALLY?
>> I'D BE A LITTLE BIT MAD
BECAUSE I'M LIKE DOING -- IT'S
LIKE REALLY HARD WORK AND SO IT
TAKES IT AWAY AND YOU'RE ALMOST
FINISHED WITH THAT THING.
>> THAT'S HAPPENED BEFORE.
HE'LL BE IN THE MIDDLE OF
BUILDING SOMETHING AND I YANK IT
AWAY FROM HIM BECAUSE I CAN'T
GET HIS ATTENTION.
>> WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN THAT
HAPPENS?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
THAT.
>> DR. VICTORIA DUNKLEY SAYS
WITH A LOT OF CHILDREN, THEIR
NERVOUS SYSTEMS ARE BEING
OVERSTIMULATED BY ELECTRONICS
AND HER RESEARCH SHOWS IT LEADS
TO BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS.
>> THE VIVID COLORS AND THE
RAPID PACE, ALL THAT IS HARD FOR
THE BRAIN TO PROCESS.
>> IT'S A PHENOMENON SHE CALLS
ELECTRONIC SCREEN TIME SYNDROME.
>> LOT OF KIDS BECOME VERY
IRRITABLE OR THEY'RE TEARFUL OR
SOME KIDS HAVE FULL BLOWN RAGES.
OTHER KIDS ARE ANXIOUS.
AND A LOT OF KIDS WILL HAVE
TROUBLE FOLLOWING DIRECTIONS.
>> A 2010 STUDY FOUND THAT EVERY
DAY, 8 TO 18-YEAR-OLDS SPEND AN
AVERAGE OF SEVEN HOURS AND 38
MINUTES USING ENTERTAINMENT
MEDIA.
BUT SOME SAY TECHNOLOGY ISN'T
THE ISSUE.
PARENTS CAN HELP THEIR KIDS TO
USE IT IN BENEFICIAL WAYS.
>> THEY CAN HELP INTRODUCE KIDS
TO NEW THINGS IN THE WORLD.
PLACES THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
THEY CAN HELP THEM PLAY WITH
IDEAS IN A WAY THAT IT'S HARD TO
HER DO SOMETIMES LIKE WITH A
PAPER AND PENCIL.
>> USED TO HAVE TROUBLE READING.
SO I USED TO DO THIS WEBSITE IT
HELPS YOU READ LIKE DIFFERENT
BOOKS.
>> DUNKLEY SAYS THE EFFECTS OF
TOO MUCH SCREEN TIME ARE
SOMETIMES MISDIAGNOSED AS
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS.
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT YOUR
CHILD, SHE RECOMMENDS A DETOX.
>> IT ALLOWS THE BRAIN TO GET
DEEP REST SO THE STRESS HORMONES
NORMALIZE.
>> AS KIDS BECOME TEENS, THE
DIGITAL BARRAGE ONLY INTENSIFIES
IN THE FORM OF SMARTPHONES.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH CENTER,
73% OF AMERICAN TEENS HAVE A
92% SAY THEY GO ON LINE DAILY.
RESEARCHERS SAY THAT PERCENTAGE
IS FUELED BY SMARTPHONES.
BRET?
>> Bret: THANK YOU.